the technology you created has linked
this poor creature
to a certain obscenity what do you have
to say to it i'm very very sorry i i
never meant it but it's it's all my
ducking fault those of us who sometimes
get the word duck instead of a certain
similar sounding curse word on our
iphones
can blame this guy my name is ken
kashenda and i invented autocorrect for
the iphone
oh yes i really came all the way out to
this farm
and teamed up with these adorable guys
to bash on autocorrect of course dr
ellen crane the owner of the safe haven
farm sanctuary has been here too to
ensure that these rescued ducks are
happy healthy and definitely not hungry
okay fine i really came out here to
answer two questions
why in certain situations does apple's
software auto correct something when you
clearly meant to type something else and
number two has apple software gotten
worse with time
that's why i tracked down ken he spent
15 years working in apple and even wrote
a book about his experience of working
on the iphone so i ran him and some
other experts through some recent auto
correct fails to find out what the duck
is going on
fail number one
random word changes
i was going to try to write software
that looked at what people did and
changed the letters out from under them
and so when i did that i wanted to be as
sure as i could be that i was giving
them what they wanted not some
ridiculous result that they didn't want
but that's not how it always works
anymore let's take one of my recent
examples to explain i use a tool at work
called news grid
but autocorrect always changes it to
news girl
as you type the autocorrect algorithms
try to figure out what you mean by
looking at various things including
where your fingers hit the keys and
other words in the sentence all the
while it's comparing your words to the
words in its dictionaries
the system that i built actually has two
dictionaries in it
the product shipped with what i called a
static dictionary you know a standard
dictionary would include all common
words and it would include include
things like names for products and
sports teams then there was a second
dictionary i called it a dynamic
dictionary and it was just this running
list of your words and your custom words
the purpose of it was to try to help you
type words that were in your own
personal vocabulary
words that were different
than words from standard english so in
the case of news grid the system is
going to the static dictionary and
replacing it with the word it knows news
girl but it really needs to add news
grid to the dynamic dictionary this
explains other issues like when
autocorrect changes a word to the name
of someone in your address book or the
name of an app on your phone
all of that info is part of your dynamic
dictionary and so then from that point
forward the static dictionary in the
dynamic dictionary would be kind of in a
little bit of a battle with each other
and it was the ultimate jobs of job of
the auto correction software to break
ties after you type a word more than two
times the system is designed to learn
that word and stopped correcting it any
further with newsgrid that hasn't
exactly happened apple said different
capitalization could impact that but
here's how you can fix an error like
that for good go to settings
general
keyboard texture placements and add the
word you want to the phrase and
shortcuts fields
now when you type this word autocorrect
should respect your typing fail number
two
no bad words
this is a duck in spilled water on my
keyboard i certainly did not have this
image in mind when i sent it to a friend
a few months ago of course i wanted to
say
here's why that happens i promise you
on the original iphone that if you typed
a certain four-letter word that begins
with f if you typed it exactly
the keyboard would leave it alone
so you could have your cusses
but if you missed one of those letters
it wasn't going to correct
to the cuss word apple did that because
it didn't want you to ever mistakenly
type a curse word or slur or another
inappropriate word and so i had to do a
study
to go out and and find all the terrible
things that people would say and
actually put them
in the static dictionary but with a
special mark on them to say
never help anybody type these words if
they type them exactly okay
but if they make a mistake
don't use autocorrect to nudge somebody
towards saying something awful so what
can you do about this
well you can type your bad words
correctly
get this
bug
you can also add those words to that
dictionary or your contacts list bye bye
ducks
fail number three grammatical errors
iran can through a couple of recent ones
i've seen sometimes i'll type
w-e-l-l well but it becomes
wheel w-e apostrophe l-l
well and wheel is particularly
challenging because both of those are
really uh common words my decision back
then was you needed to type the
apostrophe in order to get wheel
sometimes the system changes in to on or
they're just strange suggestions like
ands over time the system ken built
became more sophisticated and aggressive
correcting words based on the previous
words in a sentence
complex machine learning based on what
people have been typing on the internet
gave the system lots of new data on what
people might be trying to type
in ios 15 it's now learning from what
users type on their iphones though it's
all designed in a privacy respecting way
it's an interesting challenge because a
lot of times words new words
come into the language you know with the
idea that you're going to train a you
know essentially a web crawler to go out
and look at the words that are that
people are typing
typos are going to get into the system
and so how do you get them out well it's
probably uh you know a process that
humans are going to have to go
after the fact and clean those things up
so what can you do one option not use
apple's keyboard at all you can download
a third-party option from the app store
like google's g board one called
typewise is pretty wacky but i love that
it has an autocorrect undo button right
on the keyboard
okay so has autocorrect actually gotten
worse
well it certainly seems like machine
learning has added some more
complication to the whole system
and so the system has improved a lot
because it's been asked to do more but
therein lies the rub of like features in
you know software systems on computers
on gadgets the more you ask it to do the
more potential there is for bugs and
unexpected behaviors there may be
something to that try turning off
autocorrect yourself i bet the farm that
you will quickly realize how much good
work it's doing for you
despite the occasional duck up
all right guys for the first time i am
going to send a bunch of messages to
people where i actually mean to say duck
or ducking today